most days I will check out our reddit
discussion forum which has gotten really
active over 4,000 of our viewers and
listeners are subscribed free of course
no cost to participate to our well
moderated discussion forum it is a great
place to talk about politics all
opinions are welcome trolling is not
welcome but all opinions are welcome and
there are many conservatives over at
david pakman.com slash read it engaging
in what I would consider by and large
respectful debate a few interesting
threads that I spotted this morning on
our reddit discussion forum
congressional Democrats should work with
Republicans an interesting approach to
solving the impasse that we have in many
areas of legislation with a creative way
of how congressional Democrats could
maybe work with Republicans to advance
some democratic ideals whether it could
work or not I don't know you can check
out the discussion thread and be the
judge yourself also from our reddit
discussion forum never mind collusion
I'm starting to think that the entire
proposition of Donald Trump running for
president was a Russian idea from the
beginning you know the circumstantially
the fact that Trump and his family seem
so miserable being president and being
the first family that's the one reason
why I would think that this could have
been an idea planted by Russians in the
first place but I actually don't think
that Donald Trump is so manipulatable
that if it wasn't something his ego
already predisposed him to that he would
be convinced willy-nilly to run for
president by the Russians I think many
reasons why Russians may have wanted to
encourage it but you need a particular
type of person for it to even be on the
table to run for president so I'm not on
board with this I'm not a hundred
percent on board with this idea I
imagine that from the get code Trump
just thought that this would be just
some big advertisement for his business
yeah brand running for president and
then he would you know get out of the
race before the primary started but it
just took off and I guess he couldn't
really control it from there and at one
point there's this meeting with a former
Trump staffer who said something like
listen we met in the Oval Office and the
goal was to place a respectable second
and I don't know if that was in the
Republican primary I think it was placed
a respectable second in the Republican
primary with the idea that
ad would give Trump more notoriety and
public recognition and maybe better
deals for his reality TV show so while I
while I do believe that Trump didn't
really expect to win and that Trump is
not enjoying being president I I'm on
board with that
the idea that this was merely something
that Russians tricked Trump into doing
it's very hard for me to believe that so
I think it would be better for him if
the roles were flipped and Trump won the
popular vote and Hillary Clinton won the
electoral he was I mean he would get the
benefit of being able to go around
saying more people wanted me to be
president than Hillary Clinton and yet
he would still be in the private sector
and presumably benefit hugely from the
publicity that that would bring also on
our reddit discussion forum if the
opportunity arose do you think David
would have a conversation with Trump of
course I would that I can't believe that
this is even a question obviously if a
sitting president wanted to be
interviewed by me of course I would talk
to them and the person who proposed this
said I personally think David's too much
of an intellect who would turn down an
interview with the President of the
United States Pat I mean what would be
your opening question that that's a
whole can of worms how do you even say
are like if I could ask Donald Trump one
question what would I propose to him I
think I would start with are you
enjoying this genuinely are you enjoying
being president of the United States
yeah and you know he would probably give
some version of a yes but it would
probably be pretty transparent you
probably wouldn't answer your question
you just go on and on about eyes making
great deals and the rest you say well
listen you know I started my business
with a small loan of a million dollars
right and what we're doing here we're
doing big things and people tell me
Ivanka is great the kids are great and I
talk to generals I talk to the world
leaders all around the country we go
Air Force One they've got spare blood of
mine on Air Force One in case something
happens it's amazing what they do with
technology these days baron is so good
with computers so listen we're doing it
and the fake news media won't tell you
that but they are doing it tremendous
okay also from our reddit discussion
forum why don't we ever hear about
capital flight capital flight is an
economic term and as the thread starter
here indicates it occurs when assets or
money flow out of a country due to an
event of economic consequence yeah we
talk about economics about capital
flight that much although we do talk
about outsourcing and outsourcing is a
form of capital flight insofar as it is
moving wages to other countries even
though a lot of the profits derived from
those wages stay within American
companies I think that that's an
interesting topic and maybe something we
could look into a little bit more
anything you want us to talk about
anything you want to talk to other David
Pakman show viewers about you can
propose and start a new thread at david
pakman.com slash reddit